hello everyone and welcome back to
another episode of the road
2000 as always my name is caleb denby
and today i wanted to bring you
uh exciting news chess is back in st
louis kind of
um so of course the st louis chess club
is actually hosting
uh five of usa's strongest players
uh who are trying to qualify for the
fide world cup
so what does that mean that means in st
louis five players are playing
virtually in the americas qualifier uh
so the
americas the continents actually get to
send eight players
to the world cup and right now the
qualifying event is going on
and uh i want to start with this young
talented player andrew tang here
uh who actually just demolished his
opponent in this round jose
daniel hemi um hopefully i'm not
butchering that pronunciation too too
badly by the way
uh yeah hello everyone in the chat uh
yet again another new setup here i think
we're gonna be back to normal
before too long uh high hopes for for
next week or the week after but we'll
see
anyways this game andrew tang has the
white pieces he starts off with this
move d4
c9 f6 knight f3 g6
and knight bd2 uh by andrew here so
uh pretty interesting opening by andrew
tang let's move knight b to d2
probably strikes some of you as a little
bit odd but we'll see that
andrew actually has a very interesting
idea in mind
so of course when you are this strong uh
you want to control the center
as much as possible so we see every
actually playing pawn to
d5 here of course bishop g7 would be
keeping in line
more so with the king's indian defense
whereas after d5 it is going to be more
like grunfeld
but black has successfully avoided some
of the most testing lines
due to the slightly weird move order by
andrew
so after d5 i'm really curious to see if
you guys at home
have any interesting ideas uh
andrew came up with a pretty interesting
opening idea here with the white pieces
and i want to see if you guys at home
are going to be able to
find something so already right off the
bat what can we do with white here
what are some ideas
hello nibiru so alex says e4 jeff says
c4 is very natural
and yeah both of those moves i i well
okay e4 is not so good
e4 is actually defended a few too many
times but
c4 is a very natural idea um
and as i say that i think i just lost
the chat room for a moment so i'll get
the chat room back
but uh e4 not so good that that square
is defended a few too many times
but c4 is in fact perfectly natural
um but andrew actually came up with
something better so rather than
these ideas that you often see players
with the white pieces going for
andrew found something to pretty
successfully sort of stunt
black's play right from the get-go so of
course in the grunfeld
what is the main idea that you're going
to see players with the black pieces
going for
well it's going to be c5 right black is
going to try to get this bishop onto g7
play c5 rip open the dark squares and
activate the bishop like this this is
sort of the big point of the grunfeld
so andrew's move is actually the
immediate b4
by choosing such a strange move order
leaving this bishop here on c1
and not bringing this knight out to c3
andrew really does kind of afford
himself this extra option
that you otherwise wouldn't normally see
it does come with the downside of
weakening some of these squares but with
the massive upside
of preventing black from playing the
move c5 uh really kind of ever
um as we'll see so in the game
black said all right you are pushing
your pawn i
want to make sure it is over extended so
black does so with the strange looking
move a5 and already
we're leaving uh pretty well known
territory here generally
players with the black pieces just play
bishop g7 in this position
and it develops sort of as normal and
this has been seen at pretty high levels
of play i
think there's a magnus mvl game here
there's a boris gelfand game with the
white pieces and if boris is playing it
then he can be pretty certain there are
some good ideas here but after a5
we're pretty well off the beat path um
andrew goes ahead
and pushes through with b5 again this
pawn serving the same function here
ready to take on passant should c5 ever
be played
it comes with the added bonus of keeping
this knight a little bit at bay
as well we see bishop g7 and now just
development is normal for andrew
with this annoying looking pawn on b5
black gets castled as well we see bishop
e2 and now
uh jose decides it is time to play c5 so
of course
the whole point of andrew's opening is
to try and get a lock on the c5 square
so we see b take c6
b takes c6 and now of course
what should andrew's next move be i
think this one is actually pretty
important if you want to have any chance
of fighting for an advantage
so black to move here you want to stay
consistent with andrew's opening idea
and yeah i am serious about b4 i am
serious
andrew was deadly serious about b4
uh and sometimes you can do stuff like
this you'll you'll see ideas like this
in the kerala con sometimes
uh where you know white from the get-go
kind of knows what pawn break black is
playing for
and just takes an early early approach
to trying to stop it with something like
b4
and then as jeff and chess bunzo are
saying now uh we want to control c5 even
more
so knight b3 is one way of doing that
but even better
is to develop the final minor piece into
the game with bishop a3
and we are still in um territory where
there are a couple games from this
position
uh there's one between narcav and wei yi
back in 2018
so this is a pretty you know hot topic
lately for these top-level players in
the grundfeld
trying to just keep the c6 pawn
backwards and make use of the c5 square
we see knight bd7 by black
and now andrew goes ahead and just
castles
at this point you might be wondering if
c5 is playable
and it might be but at this point white
has enough development
that you might be able to get away with
just capturing this pawn and hanging
onto it
which is why we see black playing rookie
8 instead just
going for this pawn break since white
has committed so heavily to this other
side of the board
uh so now how do we continue
with white here we have kind of put as
much pressure on
these dark central squares as possible
we played a very preventative game so
far trying to keep black's
pawn breaks at bay but now how do we
actually ramp up the pressure
and continue here what's our next step
with white
we are completing our opening now
transitioning to a middle game and we
need
something to play for
nj says rookie one
so you're in the right direction there
uh we've developed all of the minor
pieces
now we want to look at bringing our
rooks somewhere useful
and we want to look at improving our
minor pieces even further generally
that's what you want to be doing
straight out of the opening
looking to improve our pieces further
and activate the rooks
so in the game uh what andrew comes up
with isn't necessarily
the natural looking rook b1 but instead
it's this nice move
c4 so kind of further highlighting how
black has this
awkward backwards fun and is unable to
play c5
but since we have the white pieces and
we get to move first we are actually
going to be in time
to play c4 get rid of our own backwards
pawn and then after bishop a6 by black
we can bring this rick to this nice c1
square and start ramping up the pressure
uh down this c file even further so c4
nice idea to give the rook something to
do on the c1 square rookie one
just a little bit slow doesn't really do
enough
we need our moves to be developing with
a purpose not just developing
but developing with a purpose uh we see
black go ahead and play rook c8 here
trying to match andrew on this c file
and andrew just plays this nice little
move h3 now
just improving the position further
giving his king a flight square
and uh i guess potentially preventing
knight g4 in some instances
uh so now the question is with black how
do you want to try
to equalize because as it kind of sits
andrew has managed to
keep a good hold on the game so far you
kind of have this flow
where both sides are developing and for
the moment there is a little bit of
pressure on black's position
you see this pawn is still going to be
backwards and you see that um
white is going to be the one who's
always deciding when to open things up
with d5
or c takes d5 so what can we do here
as black to try and equalize
start putting pressure on c6 push the c
pawn queen a4 so yeah queen a4
definitely one of the moves that's on
the cards
for andrew um
he didn't play it last move probably
because of some
specifics that i'm not seeing probably
because of some specifics that i'm not
seeing yes so
queen a4 and
uh
i'll talk about that
momentarily momentarily
so after h3 yeah the reason why queen a4
is bad is the the same move that black
plays here so
jeff has the same idea as uh jose with
the black pieces rather than
um e5 by mr monster which is also i
think reasonable
c5 is definitely the equalizing try
and this is always the problem you run
into
when uh playing i guess just playing
chess this is the problem that you run
into
um black generally has an idea where if
they can play this idea then they can
equalize
but the trick is to understand if you're
playing it too quickly
uh or if it is in fact the proper moment
moment so c5 is that move for black here
if black can get away with c5
and not give up anything then black is
going to be fully equal
but the question is do the tactics work
out for black is c5
actually playable here or can andrew get
some kind of advantage and in this case
it looks like andrew can get an
advantage after c5 so
for example if queen a4 then the
refutation of this is actually going to
be c5
because uh black is going to be able to
equalize here why is that
well because after h3 c5 in the game
andrew's nice idea is to
take on d5 and we are unable to do that
if our queen's on a4 we need the queen
back here on d1
supporting the bishop on e2 so we can
play c takes d5
now how do the tactics work out bishop
b2 queen e2 has to be played
um and then perhaps black
could have played the move knight takes
d5
and then at the end of the day we're
going to see a lot of trades on the c5
square
and
white is gonna be up upon at the end of
the day um those last couple moves not
necessarily forced
but the point i'm trying to get across
here is andrew is just sort of winning
upon
if black plays simply and that's the
point
so black thought well why don't i
refrain from taking on d5 for now
and go ahead and take on d4 first
so this was black's idea to try to not
go down any material
but what is wrong with this plan for
black
what's wrong here
what is wrong
i'm not sure what uh the chat means by
knight e4
now do you mean knight d4 i was going to
say 94 for either side would be hanging
a piece but knight d4 might be a little
more reasonable
might be a little more reasonable
center control so center control isn't
exactly
a suggestion for the best move but it is
the right idea and mr monster
has it as well um it's this move e4
and unfortunately for black i think c5
might have just been played a little bit
too early you have to be willing
to go down the pawn if you're playing c5
because this position is actually quite
bad
for black now it's not going to be very
easy
at all to keep a hold of the d4 pawn and
in the meantime
white is sort of taking over the entire
center of course
if black tries to uh make it a little
more symmetrical in the center
with pawn to e5 we are just able to take
on passant
and capture on d4 amongst other things
we could also just let
this pawn sit here we could even just
let this pawn sit here
and uh play something like knight c4 for
example and life is just going to be
very very difficult
for black regardless um so e4 the star
move
by andrew here seizes the advantage out
of the opening but that's not why i want
to show you this game
game gets much more fun from here so now
white has the advantage because this
pawn is not long for this world
and white has this nice central space
advantage going to be a tough game for
black from here
but black tries this move knight h5
defending the d4 pawn with the bishop uh
andrew simply plays g3
uh keeping this knight out of f4 and
just shoring up the position a little
bit look for king g2 a little bit later
just to keep everything together
and now black tries the immediate e6 to
try and shake loose some of these pawns
in the center
for white so the question is now
can we play this move d6 or is that pawn
going a little bit too far and this is
something
that um i often struggle with in my
games personally
whenever i push the pawn to d6 you know
generally it's
usually really really good but sometimes
that pawn just gets taken because it's
just so
far away from the white pieces in this
case andrew realized that he can play d6
and hold on to this pawn and because of
that his position is just very very very
good
um black plays queen b6 now we get this
nice move king g2
taking the time to just uh defend all
the weak spots
rook c3 now by black and knight b1
is the nice idea by andrew defending the
bishop kicking the rook out
so the rook has to go back to c8 and now
we just see andrew
bringing in the rest of his major pieces
e5 finally comes for black and we see
knight back
uh to d2 and bishop f8
so um we have this position where black
seems to have made a lot of progress
towards untangling right black did
manage to get these pawns to e5 and d4
didn't end up losing this pawn on d4 but
in return
we see this sort of monster pawn sitting
here on d6
for andrew tang so the question is now
how do we keep
up the pressure how do we keep up the
pressure as
andrew here because otherwise black is
just going to capture
our pawn we're going to be very very
very sad
so very very sad
road to 2000 should have a sponsorship
from sprite i tend to agree
i tend to agree
yeah dave thinks i'm losing elo because
i cut my hair
i think you might be onto something
you're not the first person to make this
joke
um i i did read a comment on the last
video that said uh they preferred
uh hobo caleb to uh to this this haircut
version of caleb so
you know give me a few months and maybe
hobo caleb will be back so
yeah the chat room is suggesting knight
c4 and unfortunately knight c4
isn't really all you want it to be uh
and the reason for that is this move
queen b5 defending
the pawn on e5 and also pinning this
knight
uh pretty awkwardly actually all of a
sudden black is gonna have some threats
like knight to b6
and you might uh find yourself in a
little bit of trouble uh trying to
hold on to this knight on c4 can't play
anything like rook d1
because we'll just take this guy and uh
the pressure
on d6 is only going to increase with
stuff like rook c6
and rook uh e to c8 to come so knight c4
not really going to get it done it's
still a playable position for white
but knight c4 not quite good enough same
thing with rook takes
um followed by knight c4 just not going
to be good enough here with this move
queen b5 coming on the board in fact
you might be close to losing a piece
probably not quite because you have the
smooth knight d2
but definitely not super comfortable
for white
so the key thing to realize here which
um this is the part
that i often struggle with in my games
is that the pawn on d6
is strong for a number of reasons you
know the most obvious one
is that when your pawn gets to d6 it's
really close to queening
and if you can push that pawn through
the last two squares then you get an
extra queen right that's the big
advantage of having a far advanced pawn
however there are other advantages and
in this case
number one it takes away some really key
squares and it does a good job
of sort of you know hindering black's
pieces this pawn is really keeping
black's pieces
from coordinating together you see that
this bishop and this knight
don't don't do a great job of working
together
and uh these pieces have trouble
sort of switching from the queen side to
the king's side because there's all
these pieces in the way
on the d file so the trick here is to
use the b
pawn um sort of as an attacking piece
use the b-pawn
or not the b-pawn use the d-pawn to
activate the rest of your pieces
without worrying too much about keeping
it absolutely 100 defended
and so that's what andrew does here so
he does actually play this move rook
takes c8
but now the follow-up is going to be
rook to b1 so
andrew isn't really wasting time trying
to defend this passively with knight c4
he's just looking to bring the pieces in
on the queen side
and use this pawn as a nice attacker
black plays this move queen a7 which is
maybe a little bit suspect
once again because of this idea where
it's super hard to
switch sides once your piece gets stuck
on one side so maybe a little bit better
it's actually this move queen to d8
because now
the queen just has a little bit easier
access to the king's side if needed but
queen a7 played instead
by the way what's wrong with queen to c6
you're probably wondering well
simply queen rook back to c1
and uh andrew would be very happy with
this position with the rooks off the
board and the queen invading
so that's why we see queen a7 and now
andrew brings in the queen as well with
queen b5
and compared to those positions with the
knight on c4
now you can definitely see that andrew's
pieces are
invading and a lot more active here um
so we see this move rook to b8
and this is kind of uh black's last hope
to keep things in the game uh get the
the rook on b1 off the board
maybe try and draw this knight backwards
so what are we going to play
after rook b8
what are we going to do after rook b8
and i'll give you guys a gold star
one gold star i don't give these out
often so if you
can find andrew's next move i'll award
you
one gold star
what about knight takes c5 i don't think
there was ever a moment when knight
takes e5 was uh was quite playable
um i think it's it's always been
defended our last move was queen b5 to
add the second attacker but now our
queen's attacked
all right mr monster says queen d3
boring boring boring boring queen d3
how could you be so boring um you're a
little bit better
after queen d3 but then black is
actually getting this
idea of taking on b1 and you know black
has some activity as well you're going
to have a difficult time
holding on to everything here so queen
d3 is what your opponent wants you to
play
queen d5 okay that's a little bit less
boring a little bit less foreign queen
d5 is a pretty good move
um white is going to be significantly
better after moves like queen d5 and
queen c6 keeping the queen active
but again you know black is going to
take on b1 and you've got some work to
do before you get these pieces back into
the game so of course
our gold star winners are simon and jeff
with the move queen takes d7 you know
who needs the queen we're all about
activating our pieces and using our
d-pawn as an attacker
and that's what's happening here so
queen takes d7 the queen's sacrifice
turns out to be the best move and it's
just completely crushing here
for um for andrew black takes
uh back with the queen now we get rook
takes b8
knight e5 and d7 is a devastating threat
so we see the move f6 by black
and now how do we finish off our
opponent here
how do we finish off the opponent
what to do in this position because i
know
i know that when i awarded you the gold
star you saw this far
and you knew you knew this next idea was
ending the game
otherwise i wouldn't have given you the
gold star
yeah so jeff of course gold star
recipient had the right idea
we go knight c4 uh black plays king g7
because what else do you play with black
and now knight b6 dislodges this queen
but we're not done yet
we're not done yet queen a7 and we do
have to find one more tactic here
what was the point what was the point of
it all
yes simon other gold star recipient a
little bit slower than jeff
but uh still finding knight c4 to b6
just a little bit slower than jeff
oh and a couple people falling at the
last hurdle here
d7 loses because your rook is attacked
one time um but of course the gold star
recipients are all over it as is chess
fun so
rook takes that f8 is the winning idea
and now there's simply no way to stop
this pawn from queening
if you take with the king this is check
king cannot stop the pawn and we get a
brand new queen with two extra pieces
and not taking doesn't really help
either
because i still play d7 my rook's
defended now and d8
is unstoppable so after rook takes that
f8
uh andrew's opponent threw in the towel
and resigned
no there's no silver stars you got two
gold stars were given out tonight that's
more
more than normal uh for that stunning
queen sacrifice
so i wanted to show you this game
because of course it has a really nice
queen sacrifice
and andrew just like crushed but uh it's
also just a very clean game from andrew
so
it goes to show uh one of the ways you
can fight for an advantage in the
opening
is with these slightly off beat lines uh
it's
more of a psychological edge than an
objective edge in many many cases
although andrew's position was
objectively good out of the opening um
but what do i mean by that well when
your opponent
is used to playing the grunfeld and
they're used to playing c5 on like move
six um without really any issues
then if you prevent c5 really early on
they're gonna have to adapt their
gameplay
uh pretty seriously right you're gonna
have to change your plan around you're
gonna have to play something
you're probably not quite as familiar
with and that's the real power
in playing something like b4 is putting
your opponent a little bit off their
game
and making them play something they're
less comfortable with that's a huge huge
advantage in any practical game
and andrew did it very well here um so
we see this pawn back on c6
and then uh after
the opening moves we see andrew waiting
with h3
acknowledging that queen a4 runs into
this move c5
and after h3 our opponent got a little
bit antsy
played c5 and was just worse after c
takes d
so andrew putting his opponent on the
back foot straight out of the opening
and then using the central advantage to
convert into a win
not by focusing um you know tunnel
vision on the d-pawn
by using the d-pawn to activate the
other pieces on the queen side
and then the tactics just flowed are
flowed
yeah flowed from there uh all right so
questions on this game
by andrew tang here questions on this
game
how many games will i be showing it
depends on how much time i have uh we're
already a half hour in
i'm hoping to get through two more
thanks for the lesson we're not done yet
nicholas we're not done yet so
hopefully that was exciting enough for
you guys with the queen sacrifice
because get ready to be bored okay get
ready to be bored we're looking at
varacobian now with the white pieces and
var
is perhaps one of the strongest players
in the world
at the one the only exchange slot i love
it dude i
love it var the exchange slav master all
he does
is win with the exchange slot how can
you not love it so
c takes d5 and var is an exchange slav
purist i do like a tricky move order
here try to go bishop f4 and bishop d3
and trick my opponent into some stuff
var wants none of that
he develops his knights knight f6 knight
f3
knight c6 bishop f4
and he says you know what i'm i'm better
because i get to move
first in these positions um yeah he
plays knight c3 and knight f3
var is as pure as it gets for the
exchange slav
uh so we see a6 now by black black can
play
any number of moves um rook c1 is
var's choice in this game we see bishop
f5
e3 by white e6 by black
and now uh white to move and you know
try to play for an opening advantage
here
uh there's really only one way to do it
without
the game devolving into a pretty simple
draw
only one way to keep the game going here
and it's a thematic idea uh both in the
exchange slav and really any opening
where black is developing this light
squared bishop
it's a rookie mistake developing this
light squared bishop honestly
the best square for the light square
bishop is c8
i'm talking like a french player it's
ridiculous
no not a3 not a4 so in any d4 opening
when you see this bishop come off of the
c8 square early on
your first thought should be about this
b7 pawn
and that is white's avenue to trying to
find an advantage in this case as we go
after this b7 pawn early on
and when this bishop is developed it can
actually be a little bit tricky
for black to defend this pawn
comfortably so we're going to play the
move queen b3 here
and this is barr's opening idea to try
and give black
some problems of course white is
perfectly fine after bishop d3 which
takes d3 and queen takes d3
but black's not going to have any
problems in this position sort of at all
you can also play the move bishop e2 can
also play something like 95
but again these moves don't really apply
any pressure at all
early on in the opening so we're looking
at queen b3 for var
and black chooses the slightly offbeat
line with rook to a7
so while this move does look sort of
very very strange the idea is that
eventually this b-pawn is likely going
to move
and the rook will have access to all
sorts of squares uh on the seventh rank
uh perhaps it could double up very
easily
and for the moment it is just a nice
defender of this d-pawn
slightly uh well i guess not more normal
rook a7 is the normal move here
but something like bishop d6 is also
playable uh playing it kind of as a pawn
sacrifice even bishop b4 has been played
before
and i think knight a5 is playable as
well although that one's not showing up
um where it should no okay so now that i
put it on the board yet there are some
games after knight a5
but rook a7 is the quote-unquote main
line uh
var continues development with bishop e2
we see bishop d6 now
by black trading off these bishops a
little bit early
take take castles castles and now
nye day for furvar is the sort of
classic idea
in the exchange slav white has an extra
tempo
and white uses that extra tempo to try
to plant this knight somewhere nice
on the queen side um now
black starts doing some pretty strange
things here so
believe it or not i actually do think
black is under some pressure out of the
opening
in this exact position so because of
that
black doesn't really have a ton of time
to waste in my opinion
i think black needs to be playing pretty
actively on the queen's side
or else white's going to be able to
build up some kind of permanent
advantage over there
so with the black pieces here what can
we do
to try and level out this game before
whites
gets any advantage was this a blitz game
no this is
uh classical time controls although they
are playing online
these are games from the qualifier for
the feed a world cup
uh the americas qualifier so uh
qualifying for the world cup can be a
pretty complicated process if you're not
like 2700 if you're 2700 they just like
send you an invitation i think
but uh the rest of those lowly gms they
have to qualify for it and in this case
the americas the continents send eight
players
and uh these are games from the us
players playing from st
louis right now that are trying to
get one of those eight qualifying spots
which by the way i think alejandro
ramirez
is in the midst of a tie break for
his uh qualification spot
uh he tied or he drew his game today
and so uh he is
actually yes he is currently playing his
tiebreak match
against franco vallejos
and we eagerly await his result there
hello asan
is it night a 40 blender isn't knight a5
a blunder
i'm not sure we'll take a look take a
look so nicholas has a great idea in the
form of
e5 so e5 is a very thematic idea here
for black
to try and negate white's queen side
advantage
you've often heard the saying i'm sure
you want to counter an attack on a flank
with an attack in the center
and that sort of holds true here
although it's even more direct in this
case
in this case white wants to put this
node in c5 and so black
very very often will counter attack in
the center of the board by playing the
move e5 but
i do think it's a little bit early to
play e5 in this instance it's a lot like
the previous game that i was talking
about where black perhaps rushed a
little bit to play c5
andrew got a concrete advantage because
black just simply wasn't set up enough
to play the pawn break and that's going
to be the case here as well
so because of this awkward positioning
of the rook on a7
um i think something like queen b6 and
all of a sudden you can see
that the white pieces are going to start
to invade
just a little bit just a little bit here
with ideas of doubling on the c file
ideas of pressuring this this b pawn
still ideas of knight c5 even
and white's going to have some advantage
so we're not quite ready to play e5
uh so there are a couple ways that black
can
equalize here i think the simplest is
actually to play knight d7 immediately
once again uh shoring up control over
the e5 square a little bit more
and already in fact countering this idea
of knight c5 so knight d7 i think is
probably the easiest way to do it and
we're gonna see this rook
land on c5 rather than a knight and i
just think this position is a lot easier
to handle
for black than uh the other way to
equalize which is with
b5 although i do think b5 is perfectly
playable as well
you get something very very similar
after the move knight e4
but in the game black actually plays
this move bishop g4
and it takes a lot to be losing in the
exchange slot
so i don't think black is losing at all
but i do think that this is perhaps
a little bit early to be initiating this
trade
so black in this instance rather than
dealing with the situation on the queen
side or the center
decides that he wants to take off the
knight on f3 before playing e5
and i think it's just a little bit early
to be doing that because as we all know
bishops are better than knights um so
trading the bishop for the knight while
it does
help initiate this e5 pawn break i do
think it is giving white a slight edge
in the form of having a bishop versus
black's knight
and so we're going to see var take this
tiny advantage
after h3 bishop f3 bishop f3 and
try to turn it into something bigger so
black plays this move
b5 we see var just plant the knight on
c5 as intended
and now we see the fruition of black's
plan with e5
uh taking advantage of the fact that
this knight on f3 is no longer there
so with the white pieces here now we
have
some type of you know tiny tiny
static advantage because we have this
nice bishop on
f3 so how do we keep this tiny stat
static advantage and not let black
simplify things
too much
so our job here with white is to keep
black from simplifying into nothing
hello adi in the chat speaking of adi
chandra in the chat
there is another chandra playing from
saint louis
uh and his name is akshat so i think
akshat did well today
as well and is advancing to the next
knockout round
so pretty good day in st louis
for the american gm's
so this one is not too uh
complex you you really only have two
options here you can take on e5
or you can defend your d-pawn somehow so
the thing i want wanted you to realize
is that we probably shouldn't take on e5
in this instance because after knight e5
i'm gonna have to work very hard to keep
this bishop alive um
and if we do then knight e4 is all of a
sudden coming with tempo
and it's white who's getting pushed back
and black is going to be able
to simplify things a little bit more
favorably here
than uh than otherwise so i think var
makes the right choice
in playing uh queen to c3 just defending
the d
pawn and now after takes takes we see
that this bishop gets to stay here on f3
applying a little bit of nasty pressure
to the light squares and black's camp
and because of this pressure we'll see
that black is just never able
to feel fully comfortable even if
objectively the position
is equal uh it's just a little bit more
comfortable for white because you see
this annoying bishop on f3
pressuring this pawn on d5 it's active
knight on c5
and in the meantime black's pieces are
just a little bit more passive
than whites we see rook c8 now by
rodriguez
uh g3 by varukovian just again
similar to the andrew tang game once
again uh improving the pawn structure on
the king's side
look out again for king g2 just to get a
really safe structure
for the king um g6 now by black
and var isn't doing anything crazy here
we just see queen to d2
eyeing some of these new holes on the
king's side stepping off
of the same file as the rook and still
keeping the d-pawn defended
so now rook to e8 by black rookie one is
simple enough we see rookie seven
take take and now once again
uh var just wants to keep pieces on the
board he just wants to
keep playing keep maneuvering and wait
for a slip up from the opponent
so that comes in the form of queen back
to c3
because black has vacated the c file we
see some potential tactics now
against this knight on c6
by the way it would be a little bit of a
mistake to take on a6 i think the simple
idea um
isn't actually sorry i thought it was
going to be knight d4 but i don't think
this actually works
because of uh everything that's hanging
in the position
like bishop d5 or c5 but simpler than
that is the move knight e4
forcing this queen to move and then
simply queen f6
and you don't quite have enough time to
extract your knight and uh
and keep your central pawns so var not
falling for it not taking on a6 just
plays queen c3
uh keeping things on the board once
again uh b4 now
is a decision that black makes in this
game and i really don't like this move
by black i think in this position
black sort of house everything under
control um
and it has sort of successfully
navigated most most of the threats here
and black should just keep things simple
at this point something like knight e4
trying to trade more pieces off would
have been
i think much preferable to b4 because
after b4
all of a sudden these pawns are going to
be huge targets for var and we see var
just immediately targeting them queen d3
hits this pawn on a6 and because of all
these threats uh black now
actually makes a little bit of a mistake
and plays the move knight e4
and now uh black simply isn't going to
be able to maintain this knight on e4
for very long and we see that var ends
up just winning a pawn
var first though improves his king with
the move king to g2
now after queen to f6 white to move and
win
a pawn in this position what do you
think chad
how can we move and win a pawn here
rockshot can translate to uncrushable an
excellent name for chess player i
i agree i didn't know that about akshay
i did not know that
all right how can we win a pawn here how
can we win a pawn
queen a6 simple
i'm not quite convinced with queen a6
guys
not quite convinced so queen a6 let's
see if i can do this without cheating
um what's wrong with queen a6 i think
we should be able to get away with
knight d4 in this position
so my queen's defended your queen is
attacked
if you take with the knight your queen
is hanging if you take with the bishop
i'll take your queen and then
take uh take your bishop with my rook
and black should be doing should black
be doing fine here or are you winning my
b4 pawn now oh no
oh no ah i did it i did it knight knight
e2
look i did it i tricked you i tricked
you i saw it all from the start
um big trick and then you know we don't
have to talk about what happens after
rookie one
uh because i don't know okay maybe
there's more to queen a6 than i thought
maybe there's more than queen a6 than i
thought so
uh queen takes a6 knight takes d4 uh
queen f6 knight f6 knight d3
it's apparently the best and if i play
bishop b4 here
take take on d takes e4 is the best
and e3 so you guys were right uh queen
takes a6 is actually pretty good
uh but black is getting a little bit of
counter play with e3 so i don't mind
um the way that var did actually but
queen a6 is a better move than i thought
i thought knight d4 was gonna be a
little bit too strong
uh what var did keeps things a little
bit uh a little bit more simple but
queen a6 apparently works i didn't
realize that
so what var did is actually just
extremely simple here
he says your e-pawn is attack your
knight on e4 is attacked three times and
defended twice
so he takes the free pawn here and then
uh the big trick is that after knight
takes d4 in this position
which you can't play queen takes d4 uh
otherwise i
take on um on a sit on c6 and a6
so knight takes d4 the idea for var is
to go rook c4
attacking two pieces at the same time
absolutely devastating
and so after 96 bar just captured on b4
but i guess it turns out that's uh this
queen a6 idea that i kind of rejected
turns out to actually work out pretty
well for white as well so kudos
to the chat um but var chose this one
uh i don't know if you thought it was
more simple
uh and now we see black sort of shoving
the age upon down the board hoping for
the best
but at this point white is i think just
winning here
uh because the bishop is so much better
than knight in this position
the knight's basically entombed and then
var goes ahead
and captures his pawn on a5 as well more
active king
more active pieces and he does not even
capture the pawn in a5 just yet
but makes it past a pawn and wins the
game so i kind of blew through the
conversion there
but uh once var won this pawn and got
these queens off the board
uh the rest was kind of history like the
the knight is just very very bad in this
position
the a pawn is uh uh perennial parent
or forever weak that's an easier word to
say and uh
the rest is just history for for var so
why did i want to show you guys this
game well because
it is sort of the model exchange slav
game
so it goes to show you guys that even if
the position
looks dead equal out of the opening if
you just keep playing moves
wait for your opponent to create a
weakness
then all of a sudden you can have
something to play for into winning
position
seemingly out of nowhere so it wasn't
actually the b4 move that lost the game
but i think b4 was a pretty
bad practical mistake by black all of a
sudden
white just has a lot more targets than
before after queen d3
when there's always always always going
to be problems with the a6 square
and var the pro that he is doesn't miss
his chance
and manages to convert
uh so any questions on this game and
then i think we have 10 minutes left
i'll try and blow through one more game
and we'll call it a night there
called a knight there so okay the last
one i want to show you guys we can look
at a game
from el shawn or we can look at a game
from oxshot
what do we think what do we think here
chesponzo doesn't know when it's okay to
take the time to play slower moves with
g3
and king g2 so
yeah var plays g3 in this position some
of this
is you know yes it kind of looks like a
slower move
but queen f4 is more often than not a
pretty realistic threat
or black in these positions so g3 is a
nice defensive move
um just aiming to keep the black queen
out and then the slow remove king g2
comes a little bit later uh when var
knows
knows he has time right like king g2
just sitting on the position
uh and you can very often play moves
like this when it's difficult to
improve your other pieces right so in
this position it's tough to see how var
really
improves any of his pieces right this
bishop is on a good
square as can get it's targeting the d5
pawn
as well as this knight on e4 the queen
is perfectly placed challenging a6
and still defending the center the rook
is necessary to defend the knight on c5
so why not take the time
to play this move king g2 if
you can't find the winning tactic yet
so basically you know if as long as your
moves have a purpose
even if they look a little bit slow
they're very often not going to be too
bad
so while g3 looks like a slow move it
does come with a very distinct purpose
of stopping queen f4 uh
thank you for the question because
that's important to uh to sort of
mention
all right one vote for oxshot we've got
10 minutes left so let's try
and go quickly here um oxshot plays e4
d4 against emmanuel garcia's g6
we get a modern defense with uh emmanuel
garcia going for early
queen b6 stuff with pressure on d4
we see oxshot just taking over the
center entirely
but this isn't really the part of the
game i want to talk about too much so
we're going to keep blowing through it
here we get b5 knight c5
take take and queen a5 bishop d2 queen
a4
um ants i want to pause here for a
moment
and see if we can find a plan for oxshot
so it's a pretty interesting position
here the center is
entirely closed so where do we look to
now for our plans
which direction should we be headed
which way should we be headed here with
the white pieces
mr monster has trouble with close
positions well boy oh boy this is the
game for you
middle fingers is 96 jeff likes g4 well
what's our plan
what's our plan here
see a vectron says king side and that's
exactly right
so uh whenever you're playing these
positions
uh with white especially you often end
up as the side with more space
in the center and when the center is so
closed like this of course
excuse me sorry um of course the play is
going to be on the flanks because the
center is so closed
so how do you decide which side of the
board to play on well
generally you play on the side where you
have more space
you've probably heard this rule as you
play on the side where your pawns
point but more accurate is to say you
play on the side where you have more
space because you have more room to
maneuver
more room to deal with the opening of
lines on that
side so even though our king is on the
king's side here we are going to be
looking at playing moves like g4
and f5 on the king's side um i like this
plane a lot better than trying to
do some random nonsense where we try to
play a4 because we don't have as much
space on that side right black
is the one with the pawn on b5 and could
potentially play a5
getting extra space over here so we're
gonna play g4
black actually castles king side king
age one by
white is always a good improving move in
these positions now we see rook a to e8
and my question is should we play f5
here
why or why not this is a key moment here
so uh essen wants to play f5
and sack the rook if the knight takes on
f5
how do we feel about that is the
sacrifice working is it worth it
jeff says premature well how would you
better prepare it then jeff how would
you better prepare it if it's premature
[Music]
all right so i won't leave you in too
much suspense um
of course of course of course we need to
play f5
now transferring the knight to e3 is
going to be quite an undertaking
if you ever do get there one two three
four moves to get to e3
is not going to be ideal um and so of
course we are good to just play f5 here
our knight is very actively placed on
the g5 square
and of course if our opponent tries to
take with the knight we are going to
sacrifice the rook because moves like
queen h5
and rook g1 are going to be very very
powerful here for example
h6 we can probably you know i'm just
just spitballing here but i'm pretty
sure we can just play rook g1
and this is just just checkmate just
literally check me nothing to be done
there um
if black doesn't take of course try
something like
i don't know rook here
um really any move is good but uh i
imagine just something like this
and we're taking an h6 next and it's
just just very
very very sad overall very very sad
overall
um so black came up with something
better in the form
of not g takes on f5
but simply just playing f6
um and so actually
i lied when i said black came up with
something better i think that this is
actually
what black should have gone for but
white is still going to be better here
and the reason is this rule that you've
probably heard from gary kasparov
basically if you ask gary you cut the
board up
into quadrants and after something like
queen to h5 you have all of these pieces
ready to attack in this quadrant of the
board around black's king
and you're essentially playing up a full
queen uh if you ask gary because the
queen is over here on a4
just entirely out of play uh and so
this attack is is probably going to be
quite good for
white that being said i think black does
still have some chances to defend you
always are going to have some
opportunities to give back a little bit
of material
since you did win an exchange here on f5
instead though we see this move f6 by
black
and this is just far too much uh to ever
work for black here
oxshot finds the correct move knight to
e6
pressuring these two pieces and you
simply don't have time to try and place
something like rook f7 here
you're just going to get demolished
after like takes takes
and and takes for example so
king takes instead but now fg6
like it just it doesn't get better here
it just doesn't get better here um
or for black
it's just not getting better i promise
promise it's not getting better
so knight takes f5 was played instead
but now instead of white sacrificing the
exchange it's actually black sacrificing
the exchange
of course that's just not not ideal so
arc shot immediately gives the exchange
back on f5
and now the king's side is just totally
shredded white's not even down material
and we see oxshot pretty convincing
pretty convincingly uh ending the game
here so
um action actually missed queen takes h7
which was a
bit kind of a lot better than queen d7
check here and he goes queen d7
takes this pawn on c6 and now having won
this nice pawn on c6
they just transpose into this end game
which is
just completely busted completely busted
for black
the c6 pawn far too strong and emmanuel
garcia resigns
so i know we sort of zoomed through this
game to finish
by the 7 30 mark but uh
[Music]
yeah just just a tough game for black i
wanted to show off how oxshot
goes for f5 so quickly not afraid to
sacrifice the exchange
because you have so much extra space and
the queen is so
far out of the game for black whenever
you have these
kinds of positional advantages where you
see that your opponent's pieces are very
much blocked off
that's when these types of sacrifices
can be good and actually recognizes that
how to best play as black in this closed
position to be honest i kind of hated
black's opening on the whole
i think this queen a5 queen a4 idea
which is very very flawed i think um
yeah i think white is just much much
better here to be honest with you
just much better
um so
what can you do better maybe you can
play something like a5 so
like i said whenever you're in closed
positions you want to play on the side
where you have more space
for black you actually just have to play
on the queen side here even if you don't
have
more space it's kind of the same amount
of space so whenever you play this move
b5
you're essentially shutting down all the
play on this side where you have more
space
and so you're just giving your opponent
a free attack so i really hate this b5
move first of all
and then this queen at 5.84 stuff just
puts the queen further out of play
and uh akshat was able to have a free
attack from there so i would have
preferred something like a5 something
like b6
c5 a5 these kinds of ideas to try and
open up
more files on the queen side for black
with that in mind though we are going to
be calling it here
as ben says in the chat josh fidel is up
next
uh with the gm class so go ahead go
check it out link's in the chat
um as always i want to say thank you
very much for joining me here on the
road
2000 hopefully you guys are enjoying
these games if you do want to follow
these games live as they're happening or
see some more results for yourself
i do believe they're available on a few
different websites i i've been looking
at them through chess bomb
just look up fiji world cup america
qualifiers and that's the name of the
tournament
hoping that we get five players from the
us and the world cup from this
qualification stage
alright once again thank you all very
much for joining me
as always my name is caleb denvey and i
will see you next time
goodbye
you